بيان قمه يؤكد ان قوات الحلف النوويه تعد
اكبر ضمان لامن الحلفاء وبايدن يتخذ اليوم
سلاح الجو الاوكراني يعلن اسقاط 11 طائره
مسيره من اصل 15 اطلقتها روسيا خلال الليل
بعد اطلاق صاروخها الثاني عشر خلال العام
الحالي
[موسيقى]
واهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا من البيان العاجل
الصادر عن قيمه النيتو في ليتوانيا حيث
اكد البيان ان الحلفاء يمتلك قدرات متفوقه
على اي خصم وقادر على تحميله كلفه عاليه
البيان اشار ايضا الى ان قوات الحلف
النوويه الاستراتيجيه تعد اكبر ضمان لامن
الحلفاء وان اي استخدام للسلاح النووي ضد
حلف سيغير تماما طبيعه النزاع وتعقيبا على
تصريحات الرئيس الاوكراني
على الوضع ان انتقاد الرئيس الاوكراني
للنيتو ووصفه الاجتماع بالسخيف اغضب اعضاء
الوفد الامريكي في القمه معتبرين اياها
بمثابه كلمات تضع ضغطا كبيرا على عاتق حلف
الشمال الاطلسي الذي لم يضع خلال القمه
المنعقده في ليتوانيا جدولا زمنيا محددا
للانضمام اوكرانيا الى الحلف
ويلتقي الرئيس الاوكراني بقاده حلف شمال
الاطلسي خلال اليوم الثاني من قيمتهم في
ليتوانيا بعد ان اكدوا ان مستقبل بلاده
يكمن داخل الحلف رغم رفضهم تحديد جدول
زمنيا انضمام اوكرانيا اليه وسيحضر
الاوكراني وهو هيئه انشئت لتحسين العلاقات
بين كييف والنيتو كما سيلتقي بشكل منفصل
مع الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ضمن مسعاه
للحصول على مزيد من الاسلحه والذخيره
مشاهدينا من العاصمه اسمعنا موفد العربيه
الى هناك نور الدين اهلا بك نور الدين اذا
اليوم الثاني والاخير لقمه
انتظره في ساعات المقبله على اجنده هذا
اليوم
يفترض ان تتشاور فيها اوكرانيا مع مع
الحلفاء ومع الحلف في كل على قاعده مديه
والمساواه بين الجانبين هذه الخطوه تعتبر
خطوه متقدمه جدا للعلاقات بين حلف شمال
الاطلسي واوكرانيا حتى وان كان هي لا تعوض
وربما لا ترضي تماما موقف سيلينس كل الذي
كان يتمنى الحصول وطلبه وزغط والحها
للحصول على موعد زمنيا على رزنامه محدده
زمنيا للانخراط في عضويه الحلف لكن هذا
الامر لم يحصل في بيان البارحه والرئيس
زيلينسكي عندما وصل اتجه الى جمهور والى
انصاره وانصاري قضيه بلاده في تحدث عن
يعني تحدث امام الالاف لكنه في الحقيقه
يبدو انه كان غاضبا من موقف حلف شمال
الاطلسي بل وصفه قبل الوصول الى هنا
وكان موقفا سخيفا فتسور ان
ما قدمه حلف شمال الاطلسي يعني على ممثلا
بالامين العام
البارحه في اجتماع ثنائيا مع الرئيس
لينسكي من تطمينات من شروحات لي الموقف
الاطلسي ربما سيخفف القليل من غضبه وخاصه
عندما سيلتقي الرئيس بايدن والذي سيحدثه
عن هذه الضمانات الامنيه التي ستقدمها
الولايات المتحده المانيا بريطانيا فرنسا
في الحقبه القادمه هو يراها ان تمهد
لعضويه بلاده ولكن امر العضويه يظل مؤجلا
يعني هو واضح ان السقف التوقعات والامال
كان عاليه بالنسبه للاوكرانيين وهذا ما
يفسر حاله الغضب التي اعترض تصريحات
الرئيس لكن هل يعود ذلك نور الدين الى
وعود ربما قدمت في الفتره الماضيه
لاوكرانيا بشان انضمامها
لا هو الحقيقه انا حسب فهم المتواضع جدا
الرئيسي لينسكي والفريق الذي يحيط به
يستخدم دائما او يضعوا دائما السقوف عاليه
جدا في طلباتهم للحصول على اقصى ما يمكن
الحصول عليه من القمه او من الحلفاء عندما
يتعلق الامر بالاسلحه هذه مساله لكن هذه
التصريحات الاوكرانيه ربما لا تاخذ بعين
الاعتبار المحذير الهامه جدا
والاستراتيجيه والجيوسيه بالنسبه لدول
كبيره مثل الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
والمانيا ودول لها مسؤوليات سواء كان داخل
مجلس امن حواله الصعيد الامن الدولي من
هنا فان
اوروبا وحل شمال الاطلسي منقسمين فيما
بينهم الدول الاوروبيه مقسمه في معينها
ودول حلف كذلك مقسمه بينها حول هذه
المقاربه تجاهها روسيا في هناك وحده وجهه
نظر ووحده مقاربه تقريبا على مدار 360
درجه مثل ما يقول البيان يتعلق باوكرانيا
ولكم جهه النظر تختلف تماما لان
الافق غامض بالنسبه لنهايه الحرب وكيف
ستكون علي العلاقه بين حلف شمال الاطلسي
وروسيا بعد نهايه هذا الحرب اذا انتهت في
وقت ما احمد سنبقى معك في متابع خلال
الساعات المقبله نودي لكل ما يحدث في قمه
كنت معنا العربيه الى هناك تردين الفريضي
قالت مفوضه الاتحاد الاوروبي ارسال ان
المفوضيه جاهزه لمساعده اوكرانيا لتقوم
بالاصلاحات الداخليه وذلك في سبيل رغبتها
في الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو
لدينا مساهمه مهمه نقدمها بخصوص رغبه
اوكرانيا في الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي والنيتو ايضا لكن لا غنى عن
الاصلاحات في اوكرانيا كتعزيز المؤسسات
ومكافحه الفساد وهنا تعمل المفوضيه
الاوروبيه بشكل مكثف مع اوكرانيا لتنفيذها
انه لامر مدهش ان نرى سرعه اوكرانيا في
الاصلاحات على الرغم من الحرب
وفيما يتعلق بالصين قال الامير العام لحلف
شمال الاطلسي حلف يتابع بقاله التعزيزات
العسكريه الصينيه وتوسيع الصين لقدراتها
النوويه
قلقون من التعزيزات العسكريه الصينيه
الضخمه وتوسيع وتطوير قوتها النوويه وايضا
نتابع انكتب وندين برنامج الصواريخ
الباليستيه لكوريا الشماليه الذي ينتهك
الاعراف الدوليه والعديد من قرارات مجلس
الامن
وشاهدنا اخر اطلاق لصاروخ من كوريا
الشماليه وهو ما يذكرنا بان هذا البرنامج
ينتهك القانون الدولي
من جهتها اعربت بعثه الصين في الاتحاد
الاوروبي عن معارات ورفض بكين الاجزاء
الوارده في بيان قيمه المنعقده في
ليتوانيا والتي تناولت الصين وقالت البعثه
ان محتوى البيان المرتبط بالصين فيه
تناقضات وتجاهل للعديد من الحقائق بشان
سياسات
ردود فعل المواطنين الروس على قمه النيتو
ولكنهم اجمعوا على تخوفهم من اقتراب حلف
من حدود بلادهم
ما يقلقني كمواطن جنسي هو ان النيتو اقترب
من حدودنا بسبب تصرفات الرئيس لقد زاد طول
حدود الدول التي انضمت اليه بمقدار الف
كيلو متر
يبدو لي ان الدول التي ستنضم الى حلف
الناتو هي تلك التي تشعر بقلق اكبر بشان
ما سيحدث في المستقبل في رايي تخشى بعض
الدول من النهايه وتحاول الوقوف الى جانب
المنتصر
رغبه اوكرانيا في الانضمام للنيتو امر سيء
للغايه من الواضح انهم تلقوا وعودا كثيره
كان يكونون اغنياء وقادرين على الوصول الى
الغاز والوقود والمعدات لكن في النهايه
ستجعلهم اوكرانيا في وضع صعب نحن روسيا
سنمزق مثل اوكرانيا في حال تبين ان بلدنا
ضعيف سيكون الامر بلا نهايه هذه هي التي
يعمل بها العالم يجب ان نكون اقوياء يجب
ان ندافع عن انفسنا
امر مخيف بصدق من غير المعروف كيف ستتطور
الاحداث لكنني اريد ان ينتهي كل هذا سلميا
وعلى صعيد دعم الحلفاء الاوكرانيه اعلنت
الحكومه البريطانيه عن حزمه مساعده جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 50 مليون جنيه استرليني
اضافيه لاصلاح المعدات وانشاء مراكز اعاده
تاهيل عسكري في اوكرانيا وذلك في اليوم
الاول من قمه قاده حلف شمال الاطلس في
وتتضمن حزمه المساعدات التي ستقدمها
بريطانيا واعضاء مجموعه دول السبع الاف
الذخائر الاضافي لدبابه اثنين واكثر من 70
مركبه قتاليه
وزير الخارجيه على ان الصراع في اوكرانيا
لن ينتهي حتى يتخلى الغرب عن خططه لهزيمه
روسيا حسب تعبيره وقال خلال زيارته
الاندونيسيا انه لا توجد اي مؤشرات على
تغير قريب في موقف الغرب وسعيه الى تعزيز
هيملته العالميه
وفي تطورات الميدانيه للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه اعلان سلاح الجو الاوكراني
اسقاط احدى عشره طائره مسيره
اطلقتها روسيا خلال الليل وقالت في بيان
لها ان الهجمات الروسيه انطلقت في مقاطعه
كورسك واستهدفت مناطق العمليات في
الجبهتين الوسطى والشرقيه ومناطق حولك وان
وحدات الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات شاركت في
التصدي للهجوم الروسي
قال مايك نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب بان حادثه ترامب عن قدرته
على انهاء حرب اوكرانيا في 24 ساعه حديث
خاطئ وقال فرنسي شبكه سي ان انه لا يمكن
انهاء الحرب في هذه المده الا بمنح بوتين
ما يريده بينسى الذي ينافس ترامب على
بطاقه ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري للانتخابات
الرئاسيه المقبله قال ان ترامب كان يناور
فقط حينما طلب منه عدم التصديق على فوز
بايدن في الانتخابات الماضيه لكن الامور
تطورت بعد ذلك
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
بتزامن مع تصعيد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
الصين ترسل طائرات مقاتله وسفنا حربيه
باتجاه تايوان
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد توتر جديد في
شبه الجزيره الكوريه بعد اطلاق كوريا
الشماليه صاروخا هو الثاني عشر في هذا
العام هيئه الاركان المشتركه في الجيش
الكوري الجنوبي قالت ان صاروخ كوريا
الشماليه اطلق بمنطقه باتجاه بحر الشرق
الذي يعرف ايضا باسم بحر اليابان
قبل ذلك التقى جنرال امريكي كبير مع
نظريها الكوري الجنوبي والياباني في
اجتماع ثلاثي النادر في هاواي بحسب وكاله
رايتز وجاء هذا الاجتماع في الوقت الذي
اطلقت فيه كوريا الشماليه صاروخها الا ان
المتحدث باسم رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكي الجنرال اكد ان الاطلاق الكوري
الشماليه حدث في خطاب الحدث في ختام
الاجتماع
وفي رد على تجربه الكوريه الشماليه قال
رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه ان كوريا الشماليه
ستدفع ثمن افعالها غير القانونيه وحسب
بيان لمكتب فقد وجه المسؤولين بتعزيز ردع
من خلال المجموعه النوويه المشتركه مع
الولايات المتحده كما طالب ايضا باظهار
تضامن الدولي ضد افعال كوريا الشماليه
خلال قمه
من جهاته اعتبر كبير امناء مجلس الوزراء
الياباني هيروكازو ماسونو الاجراءات التي
تقوم بها كوريا الشماليه بانها تشكل تهديد
للسلام والامن في المنطقه والمجتمع الدولي
مشيرا الى ان اليابان قدمت احتجاجا شديدا
لهجه على تجربه الكوريه الشماليه عبر
القنوات الدبلوماسيه في الصين
ان اطلاق الصواريخ الباليستيه يشكل تهديدا
للسلام والامن في منطقتنا والمجتمع الدولي
وهو امر غير مقبول على الاطلاق هذا النوع
من اطلاق الصواريخ ينتهك قرارات مجلس
الامن التابع للامم المتحده
ويمثل مشكله خطيره لسلامه الشعب الياباني
احتججنا لدى كوريا الشماليه من خلال
السفاره في بكين
الصين المجاوره مشاهدينا التي ارسلت سفن
حربيه ومجموعه من المقاتلات والقاذفات
باتجاه تايوان بحسب وزير الدفاع التايواني
المصدر قال ان بكين ارسلت 38 طائره وتسعه
سفن حربيه خلال اليومين الماضيين منها ما
عبر خط الوسط لمضيق تايوان الخطوه الصينيه
جاءت قبيله تدريبات العسكريه التي ستجريها
تايوان والتي تنظم بشكل سنوي وتحاكي غزوا
للجزيره
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل العربيه ان الشرطه السودانيه
عاودت انتشارها في محليه كيرير بمدينه ام
درمان بعد تراجع قوات دعم السريع في
المنطقه واظهرت مقاطع فيديو وصور وانتشار
عدد من القوات في المحليه في مناطق ام
درمان وعلى صعيد متصل استانفت هيئه نظافه
ولايه الخرطوم عمليه جمع النفايات في
محليه كرري في الوقت الذي اكد فيه احد
الضباط في الجيش السوداني استقرار الوضع
الامني هناك
ويدور الصراع العسكري مشاهدينا بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لسيطره على
المواقع الاستراتيجيه المؤثره على سير
المعارك بولايه الخرطوم واهم هذه المواقع
سلاح المدرعات وهو السلاح الاستراتيجي
الذي يمثل القوات القتاليه الجيش السوداني
بما يتوفر له من اليات ومعدات العربيه
حصلت على معلومات حصريه عن هذا الموقع
الذي تعتمد عليه موازين القوه على الارض
صوت السلاح لا يهدا في الخرطوم والحرب
الضاريه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع تدور منذ حوالي ثلاثه اشهر للسيطره
على المواقع الاستراتيجيه المؤثره على سير
المعارك خاصه هنا في اهم المواقع بالعاصمه
بالنسبه للجيش فسلاح المدرعات في الخرطوم
هو السلاح الاستراتيجي للجيش السوداني
الذي يمثل القوه القتاليه بما يتوفر له من
اليات ومعدات اضافه للسرعه والمناوره وقوه
النيران والقدره التدميريه الهائله
العربيه حصلت على معلومات حصريه عن هذا
المقر المهم
فمن يسيطر عليه يغير موازين القوى على
الارض يقع سلاح المدرعات بمنطقه الشجره
العسكريه جنوبي الخرطوم في مقر تتعدى
مساحته 20 كيلومترا مربعا يضم المقر
الرئيسي لسلاح الجيش السوداني وبه ثلاث
كتائب دبابات تي 55 اي نحو 40 دبابه
وكتيبه دبابات 72
وكتيبه دبابات تي 90 الحديثه اضافه الى
لواء اي مشاهده
بي تي ار وكذلك كتيبه مشاه بناقلات جنود
مدرعه
ظل سلاح المدرعات حصنا منيعا على قوات
الدعم السريع فالجيش رفض وجودهم باي شكل
في هذا الموقع عكس اي موقع اخر وتهمه
الانقلابات المتكرره خلال الفتره الاخيره
كان مصدرها المدرعات ما يعني ان السيطره
على المدرعات تنهي وجود القوات المسلحه في
مدينه الخرطوم
ومن اهم ميزات مقر سلاح المدرعات
الاستراتيجي السيطره على طريق جبل اولياء
الرئيسيه بمنطقه الشجره وهو احد طرق
الامداد الهامه لقوات الدعم السريع
المتمركزه في معسكر طيبه ويمكن قطع النقل
النهري عبر السيطره على مجرى النيل جنوبي
الخرطوم كما يمكن استخدام ارض المدرعات
كمهبط محمي وامن للطائرات القتاليه
الهجوميه الخفيفه حاله تعطل مطار جبل
اولياء
والمدرعات تعد سلاحا فعالا لترجيح كافه
المعارك لصالح الجيش في ظل تناقص قدره
الدعم السريع في جانب مضادات الدروع نسبه
لاستنزاف الذخائر بطول فتره الحرب
ويعتبر سلاح المدرعات مقر قياده بديلا
للقياده العامه حاله تعرضها للتدمير
في العراق مشاهدينا اعلن رئيس مجلس
الوزراء محمد شيعه السوداني عن العوده
تدريجية لتوريد الغاز الايراني ووضع حلول
لمشاكل انتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه في
المحطات الغازيه اتخذنا قرار
بالمقايضه العينيه اي اننا نعطي النفط
الخام او النفط الاسود مقابل الحصول على
الغاز الغاز الايراني بهذه الطريقه
راح نتمكن من المحافظه على
استمراريه تجهيز الغاز وبنفس الوقت
الايفاء بالتزامنا بتسديد مستحقات هذا
الغاز المستورد هذا الاتفاق
راح يوفر للعراق الاموال
ويجنبنا الاضطراب المتكرر في مساله
التجهيز مما ينعكس سلبا على حياه
المواطنين ولدينا تخصيصات ماليه موجوده في
موازنه الثلاث سنوات
قبال هذه التخصيصات سوف نقوم بعمليه
المقايضه للنفط الخام والنفط الاسود تم
التوقيع المحضر اليوم وحصل للاتفاق
اعلن مسؤولون وباحثون من شركه مايكروسوفت
ان قراصنه مرتبطين بالصين اخترقوا حسابات
بريد الكتروني في حوالي 25 منظمه وعطلوا
حسابات مستهلكين التي من المحتمل ان تكون
مرتبطه بهذه الكيانات ووفق المسؤولين
استغل القراصنه الصينيون الذين اطلق عليهم
استغلوا فجوه امنيه في سحابه مايكروسوفت
في اطار حمله مشتبه بها للوصول الى
البيانات في شبكات الكمبيوتر الحساسه حيث
اكتشفت الحكومه الامريكيه في الشهر الماضي
ثغره مقلقه لكن حينها كانت في حسابات غير
سريه
يتعرض اكثر من 50 مليون امريكي لموجه حر
شديده هذا الاسبوع تمتد من كاليفورنيا حتى
تكساس وفلوريدا حيث تتصاعد موجه حر عبر
جنوب الولايات المتحده الى نحو ثلاثه بل
نحو ثلاث واربعين درجه مئويه وحضرت دائره
الارصاد الجويه الوطنيه من وجود كتله من
الهواء الساخن فوق مرايات الصحراء
الجنوبيه الغربيه حيث تتعرض اجزاء من
اريزونا
لارتفاع درجات حراره قد يصل بل تصل الى ما
فوق ثمانيه بل 38 درجه مئويه
اعلن رئيس الامريكي جو بايدن حال الطوارئ
في ولايه الواقعه في شمال شرق الولايات
المتحده بعدما تسببت امطار غزيره بفيضانات
استدعت انقاذ عشرات السكان بواسطه قوارب
وقد وثقت صور الدرون كيف بدت شوارع
الولايه التي غمرتها المياه الجارفه
وتقطعت سور السكان من جرائها
[موسيقى]
في نهايه النص المشاهدين نذكر بابرز
العناوين
في بيان قمه الناتو الناتو يؤكد ان قوات
الحلف النوويه تعد اكبر ضمان لامن الحلفاء
وبايدن يلتقي اليوم
سلاح الجو الاوكراني الاسقاط 11 طائره
مسيره من اصل 15 اطافتها
صاروخها الثاني عشر خلال العام الحالي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات